[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este es
un magazine 100% dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y estos son nuestros titulares la junta
militar maliense que llegó al poder tras
un doble golpe de estado intensificó las
tensiones con francia a la que acusa de
buscar la partición del país y de estar
detrás de las sanciones económicas
impuestas por la sede out veremos
justamente algunas de las consecuencias
de esas sanciones en la economía del
país
burkina faso tras ser suspendido por el
golpe de estado se reanudó el juicio por
el asesinato del líder thomas sankara el
tribunal militar pidió 30 años de cárcel
contra el ex presidente bless compadre
principal sospechoso en la muerte de su
predecesor asesinado con 12 de sus
compañeros en 1987 desde uagadugú
nuestro corresponsal nos traerá los
detalles
iremos a ruanda donde una mujer
cállate sin lucha por la promoción del
fútbol femenino africano a sus 49 años
cállate se dirige a ese kigali uno de
los mejores equipos de fútbol femenino
del país
empezamos en mali las autoridades de
transición intensificaron la atención
con parís tras la expulsión del
embajador francés a finales de enero el
primer ministro acusó a francia de haber
trabajado para la partición del país y
de instrumentalizar a la comunidad
económica de estados de áfrica
occidental cedeao a finales de 2021 la
junta militar maliense abandonó su
promesa de organizar elecciones en
febrero de 2022 la cedeao consideró
inaceptable este retroceso e impuso a
mali un bloqueo económico veamos cuáles
serían las consecuencias de esas
sanciones en uno de los pilares de su
economía la producción de algodón
mahamadu con a ti cultiva su algodón en
el oeste de malí espera una buena
cosecha pero está preocupado cultivar el
llamado oro blanco es sólo la mitad de
la batalla todavía tiene que encontrar
la manera de exportarlo desde que el
bloque de áfrica occidental impuso un
embargo comercial y cerró las fronteras
con malí por el control del poder por
parte de la junta militar el sector del
algodón se encuentra en apuros
y
las sanciones no causan muchas
dificultades porque sólo el 2% del
algodón se procesa en mali el resto se
exporta al extranjero si nos sancionan
como vamos a vender nuestro algodón
aftab cofetur miles de algodoneros
malienses como mahamadu hacen sonar la
alarma el gobierno compra todo su
algodón a través de la empresa maliense
de desarrollo textil la compañía
controla el sector desde la
transformación hasta la distribución en
el extranjero pero no para nada
si las reservas financieras se agotarán
sin que nos paguen sería un desastre
el algodón es el segundo producto de
exportación de malí después del oro y
una fuente clave de divisas hay más de
cuatro centenares de miles de millones
de francos cfi circulando en el sector
del algodón en una temporada muy buena
se prevé que este ciclo de siembra
produzca 82 mil toneladas frente a las
147 mil de la anterior atraídos por los
elevados precios impuestos por el estado
más productores recurren al oro blanco y
mientras las sanciones continúan los
agricultores esperan que la apuesta dé
sus frutos
en túnez el presidente caixa ayer
extendió sus poderes el mandatario
emitió un decreto para sustituir al
organismo independiente de crear jueces
y ahora podrá aprobar y destituir
magistrados la medida suscitó masivas
protestas convocadas por la oposición en
el país ya que sólo el año pasado asad
destituyó a su primer ministro suspendió
el parlamento y asumió todos los poderes
ejecutivos también suspendió
parcialmente la constitución y se otorgó
el poder de gobernar por decreto
en burkina faso los fiscales pidieron 30
años de prisión contra hables compaoré
ex presidente del país por el asesinato
de su antecesor el ex líder thomas
sankara pero a petición de sus abogados
el juicio se suspendió hasta el primero
de marzo desde uagadugú la capital
nuestro corresponsal callidus y con los
detalles
acuso hables con pared y lo acusó de uno
de los delitos más graves de atentar
contra la seguridad del estado martilleo
la fiscala militar antes de agregar
también lo acusó de complicidad de
magnicidio para la fiscala militar el
objetivo de bless compadre y ya saca a
fondo y silver tender en el atentado del
15 de octubre de 1987 fue efectivamente
el asesinato de tomasson cara en un
intento de arresto que hubiera salido
mal como afirmaban los acusados la
acusación comenzó con el rockera torio
fonológico de los hechos de este famoso
15 de octubre fecha del golpe recuerda
que desde el primer día del juicio el 11
de octubre sólo han estado presente dos
de los 14 procesados entre el general
silvia tenderete de 61 años uno de los
principales jefe del ejército durante el
golpe de estado está preso en la cámara
de arresto y colección de los ejércitos
voces ya nos pues ya fue condenado a 20
años de prisión por su fallido golpe de
estado el 2015 el principal acusado de
la excepción ante vélez compadre que
llegó al poder por este golpe nunca
compareció en el juicio sus abogados
habían denunciado un juicio simulado
ante un tribunal excepcional fue
derrocado del poder en 2014 por las
calles y desde andantes ha vivido en
exilio en costa de marfil sin embargo el
fiscal se muestra satisfecho de haber
visto a la justicia asumir en este caso
incluso 34 años después de los hechos
para permitir que se diga la ley pero
para lucrar me va secretario general del
comité conmemorativo de thomas sankara
las empresas requeridas son
decepcionantes la audiencia fue
suspendida para permitir que los
abogados defensores preparan sus
argumentos
reanundación para el 1 de marzo y casi
dos años después del inicio del cob y 19
la organización mundial de la salud
informó que el continente está en camino
de poder controlar la pandemia según la
web es a esta predicción llega contra
todo pronóstico dadas las desigualdades
en el acceso a la vacunación es visto
mientras estamos aquí hoy finalmente
podemos afirmar que si las tendencias
actuales se mantienen hay luz al final
del túnel con to dance long a larga
historia y experiencia del continente
con grandes brotes junto con una
acumulación de aprendizaje y experiencia
desde el inicio del cobi 19 ha visto que
la respuesta se vuelve más efectiva con
cada nueva ola with the new wave
millones de personas en el cuerno de
áfrica podría morirse de hambre si no se
les entrega ayuda alimentaria con
urgencia esa es la dura advertencia del
programa mundial de alimentos ya que la
región enfrenta a las sequías más
fuertes desde la década de 1980 la
amenaza de la hambruna ha obligado a
miles a refugiarse en campamentos en una
búsqueda desesperada de alimentos agua y
refugio
a las afueras de mogadiscio en somalia
miles llegan a estos campamentos la
amenaza de morir de hambre no les deja
otra opción
algunos caminaron cientos de kilómetros
para llegar hasta aquí en una búsqueda
desesperada de comida y agua
estuvimos ocho días en la carretera
hemos sufrido y algunas personas han
muerto dos mujeres que nos acompañaban
en el viaje murieron de hambre para
aquellos que sobreviven el camino apenas
alcanza la comida los ingresos
hospitalarios de niños desnutridos ya
están en aumento la admisión que las
admisiones también han aumentado
considerablemente también las cifras de
mortalidad de estos niños con
desnutrición aguda severa
en el programa mundial de alimentos dice
que los habitantes del cuerno de áfrica
se enfrentan a las condiciones de sequía
más fuertes desde la década de 1980
advierte que millones podrían morir de
hambre a menos que se tomen medidas
después de tres temporadas de lluvias
fallidas el cuerno de áfrica se
encuentra en medio de una grave sequía
que impacta a unas 13 millones de
personas y el sur de etiopía el norte de
kenia somalia se ven afectados el ganado
muere las cosechas se pierden y las
poblaciones se ven obligadas a abandonar
sus hogares
los pronósticos de precipitaciones por
debajo del promedio podrían traer aún
más sufrimiento en los próximos meses
las agencias humanitarias dicen que
necesitan más de 300 millones de dólares
para mantener a raya la hambruna en la
región
vamos a ruanda donde ha incrementado el
interés en el fútbol femenino justo
después de que una de sus ciudadanas se
convirtiera en la primera mujer en
arbitrar un partido de la copa africana
de naciones allí uno de los mejores
equipos del país es dirigido por una
mujer que promueve el amor por este
deporte y según sus alumnas se ha
convertido en una madre para ellas
dedicate es y es entrenadora lleva unos
20 años en las canchas y actualmente
tiene al cargo a ese gigante uno de los
mejores equipos de fútbol femenino en
ruanda
habla con pasión y alienta a los jóvenes
a que amen este deporte
considero la profesión de entrenadora
como cualquier otra profesión solo que
he encontrado que en el fútbol tienes
que invertirle amarlo y perseverar en
mejorar tus conocimientos y técnicas
para marcar la diferencia en tu carrera
como entrenadora coche
recientemente este equipo se ha
convertido en el centro de atención
luego de que la ruandesa se anima muy
cansada hiciera historia fue la primera
mujer en arbitrar un partido de la copa
africana de naciones el mayor torneo
masculino del continente y es que casi
te sí estuvo a cargo del equipo en el
que jugaba muy cansada cuando era joven
no sólo entrena a sus alumnos a nivel
físico sino a nivel emocional y ellas se
sienten cómodas
tu misión draw
abbas y cada jugadora se siente libre
que nuestra entrenadora es una mujer
como nosotras entiende todas las
dificultades que podemos tenerlos a cabo
a ti ya jon se gustan a bursa aunque a
un hombre no le puedo decir nada pero
con el ir y la consiguieron nuestra
madre fuera del fútbol nos da consejos
sobre la vida un software además durante
sus tres años como entrenadora y gerente
inaes y kigali el equipo ha ganado tres
copas de campeonato y el cuarto lugar en
la liga femenina de ruanda
vamos a malawi a sus 92 años el músico
jean es ya la manda nunca se imaginó que
podría ser lo suficientemente famoso
como para cenar con el presidente y
luego pasar la noche en un hotel de lujo
pues el mes pasado hizo ambas cosas
gracias a su improbable fama conseguir a
través de tick tock que es utilizada
principalmente por adolescentes esta es
la historia
kidetza la manda no usas redes sociales
y ni siquiera tiene un teléfono
inteligente
pero eso no impidió que el músico de
malawi se convirtiera en una sensación
de 'tik tok' a los 92 años ya la manda
dice que está disfrutando cada parte de
convertirse en una celebridad
cuando canto mucha gente se divierte
están felices bailan y eso me hace
sentir muy orgulloso
vamos a cenar
en el otoño de 2020 ya la manda grabó
una versión reggae de su canción línea
que había escrito 20 años atrás como
homenaje a su hija la canción fue un
éxito inmediato en youtube y más aún en
tick tock donde rápidamente se hizo
viral y cuenta con más de 80 millones de
reproducciones
ahora ya la manda no puede salir a las
calles sin ser reconocido y sus jóvenes
fans a menudo se sienten inspirados por
la energía y la sabiduría del anciano de
92 años
me gusta la música de ella la manda
porque es un tipo mayor y obviamente
sabe mucho más de la vida
como que comparte sus experiencias de
vida y muchas cosas sensibles en sus
canciones era 206 y listo
en los últimos meses ya la manda ha
recibido decenas de ofertas para
conciertos e incluso fue invitado a
cenar por el presidente de malauí sin
embargo el músico aún no ha recibido
regalías o compensación por sus vídeos
virales en las redes sociales
[Música]
y terminamos en montevideo uruguay donde
tuvo lugar el festival las llamadas un
desfile anual para celebrar la herencia
africana del país cada año decenas de
músicos y bailarines desfilan durante
dos días por el centro de la capital
uruguaya al son de candombe un género
musical desarrollado en el país y que
tiene su origen en las luchas de las
comunidades negros
de esta manera despedimos este capítulo
de áfrica siete días gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]